My name is Chengkai Zhang.
And the project that
I have been working on
is the learning of
3D-shaped priors
that can be used to help
with other 3D tasks.
So what is a shape prior?
Basically, it's the sense of
what a shape should look like.
So for example, if I
take two random chairs
of different styles and then
I put the back of one chair
on the seat of the
other one, then
I will end up getting a shape
that can be defined as a chair,
but probably you'll say
that this chair looks weird,
it doesn't look right.
So this is because we've built
a sense of what a chair should
look like over years of seeing
different kinds of chairs.
So right now, we try to build
a neural network that models
this kind of knowledge.
So from a model pod
we train a generator
over several networks.
So these are two
networks, one of which
we call a generator
that tries to generate
a shape that looks like the
shape in a given data set.
And then the discriminator
tries to distinguish
between the generated
shape and the real shape.
So these two compete
against each other.
And when the training
converge, the generator
will be able to
sample new shapes that
looks like real shapes,
that looks reasonable.
And the discriminator
will be able to tell
if the shape looks natural.
So then we can use this
network to help with our tasks,
like 3D shape
reconstruction, so that we
can make the reconstructed
shapes also have more details
and looks more natural.